I love booze Esch is about that having
matching law thank you
so this talk is based on joint work with
my colleagues so I bought done the whole
group - Ramirez Sean mind Pascal
Pascal morale and get on vice and Sean
is here in the audience so I'm very
grateful to Sid for his talk this
morning because he introduced many
notions that will be irrelevant is this
in my talk as well and for those of you
that attended and appreciated his talk
the main difference here will be that I
will consider open matching models in
contrary to see that has closed
well matching version of cross queuing
system so I will first start with some
performance evaluation of first come
first match model and then move towards
the policies that saudis needs a less
and less information and I want to talk
with some results on optimization so I
don't think I need to go into the
details here but everyone knows to some
extent static version of matching models
that has been studied for a very long
time now since the thirties and since
then there there are many many
applications in different fields and in
the last maybe 15 years with more and
more
importance of online advertising we had
seen a new wave of results on matching
models but here in the context on online
matching in that line of work there is
one population of let's say resources
that are known in the system and then
there are requests that come according
to some stochastic process or even we
have some partial knowledge about the
processes itself and we need to make
decisions in real time and my talk will
be going further from that one side it's
dynamic matching and try to see what
happens when both populations come
according to some stochastic process in
the system and so our decision that we
need to make is how to do the matching
so here is one motivation for this type
of models which is kidney limbing donor
program so you have patients that have
family members that are willing to
donate a kidney to do this to the
relative or friend but unfortunately
they are not compatible and so they can
sign up into a program where there will
be other donors and patients coming in
in answer so the objective is to match
as many as possible of the patient donor
pairs
another application from maybe now even
more than 25 years ago is a public
housing where you have families that
come with different requirements maybe
they have kids that need to go to the
school so they required that in the
neighborhood there is a school and they
have requests for the size of the house
and also there are houses that come with
their descriptions and they're in
different neighborhoods and of different
sizes and so what what today considered
is the policy that is when a house
becomes available it is given to a
family that has been waiting the longest
longest time in the system and that is
compatible did did the house so why
first come first matched because in this
application we we have both list of
houses and list of families that are
publicly available so it is very
difficult to justify that there is a
family waiting for a very long time
there is a house that is compatible with
the family and you are not going to
allocate on these to the family so it's
a somehow is captures notions of
fairness so this was the first policy
that was implemented in this context and
so a mathematical model for this problem
has been posed by a called code enter
Kaplan and vice in 2009 and then they
started very simple examples where they
were able to solve the system due to the
state space collapse under different
simplifications on the matching
structure and then
as an advice managed to give the the
full description of the matching rates
between different types of families and
houses and so I will concentrate on the
result on the performance evaluation of
this type of models that is actually we
can prove that this first compressed
match policy has a product form so but
let me describe the model a little bit
more in detail so it is very close to
the classical call centers model from
stochastic Network networks literature
so there you have different types of
customers and different types of servers
that can serve some classes of customers
but not all of them and the matching
variant of of this skill based system is
making the complete symmetry between two
classes that about supply and demand
classes and so you replace service by
arrival streams of the other population
and so we assume that the major
matchings are instantaneous and the
items that didn't find a match are
stored in a buffer for each class okay
so in order to give you ideas on the
result for product form I will move to a
more general general class of models
where I'm removing the restriction that
the matching graph is bipartite and we
will consider any graph and so this is
compatibility the edges denote the
compatibility among different classes of
items that can come
the system we assume that this graph is
connected at the basic and just pieces
so in connected components in separation
and we have a rival sequence that our
idea according to some probability
distribution so first come first much
policy so meaning that an item that
comes in the system looks among all
possible compatible items the ones that
is the one that is staying there for the
longest time okay so people denote by W
n the word of unmatched items at time n
note that now we don't have two
populations just just one word so just
one example to make sure that model is
clear so at time 0 we have empty words
so we start from the empty system and
then here a vertical line denotes the
time so at time one we have item one
that arrived in the system and then it's
time to we assume that there is item
three that arrived in the system they
are not compatible so the current word
is one three and so on
now there is item for that can be
matched with the item three so we are
only left to get one and so on so we are
back to the empty system and we continue
okay any questions so far so uh let me
then yes yes until you you're going to
really keep the order of each of the
unmatched items
sorry 400 this is yeah this apart I've
also taken place like that it's
unfortunate that I started with one
theis here because items for three and
one compressed matched I'm looking
across the nodes okay I'm glad you asked
okay so first we are going to look into
the stability conditions for for this
and for necessary stability conditions
we will have equivalent of halt theorem
but here for the general imagine graphs
and so we will be interested in to the
arrival probability probabilities that
that does that lead to the positive
recurrent Markov chain and so these are
my necessary stability conditions but
here expressed for a general matching
graph and so Samaras and Pascal Mayan
showed that this
necessary conditions are non-empty for a
G for a graph that is connected on if
and only if the graph is not bipartite
okay so we will come back to the idea of
the proof later on but we need some
extra ingredients here so here is the
first result so for first come first
much policy we have a maximum stability
region and the stationary distribution
has a product form and look at that you
are you actually can recognize the
necessary conditions for the for the
stability so here I have a product over
the probability of a class of element WL
and here I have the probability of all
the other classes that can be matched
with the elements that are currently in
the system so okay there is
unfortunately very ugly normalizing
constant sitting here so we didn't
completely solve the performance
aviation of this model but at least we
know that it has product form and this
then can be used for answering various
questions such as for example matching
rates
okay so I'll give just the idea of the
proof this independent set for this
graph
you know the EU on top is the is the
neighbors of the independence for know
when you say ey is the neighbors of the
independence that you for I hear hear
okay so it turns out that one I only
need to look at these four independent
sets okay and so this is the all the
classes that can be matched by the
classes that are in subsets I so these
are I'm starting from the compatibility
graph that was given previously exactly
and strictly less so it's really similar
to what a sitter shot for the bipartite
case okay so I'll give you just the idea
of the proof because I find it's quite
intriguing because we struggled for
years to try to show the product form
and it turns out that we didn't include
enough of information so it turns out
that when you include much more
information in the system then
everything simplifies and then on this
detailed description of the system you
can show the product form and then you
also obtain the product form for the
system via we want to study and let me
just give you a notation for this that I
will use in detail description so this
is just reversal of the word and we also
need a ghost space to memorize who got
matched with whom in the past so the go
space is just the copy of the ridge
protect space and sometimes we would
like to mix the items and their ghosts
so I will denote this in bold
okay and so then we define two processes
that are that live on these words whose
elements are in both V so first chain is
the chain the tracks the history and we
are going to at each time n we are going
to look what is the oldest unmatched
item in my system and from that oldest
unmatched item until the current time
I'm going to track either the identity
of the unmatched item or the ghost of
the item that got matched with my item
so similar for the future I'm going to
define a future chain that that looks at
the the item that is going to be matched
the furthest in the future with an item
that we already observed and I'm going
to also mark the the ghosts for the
matched items and leave the items is
there for unmatched so to understand
this here is an example so here as I
said I'm observing item 1 and it is
going to be matched with item 2 so I'm
already marking this item by ghost of 1
okay and here's how chains
B and F evolve
and for these chains I can show that
they both admit the stationary
distribution that is extremely simple
and the way to prove this is to show the
reversibility but it is only possible on
these chains and it's extremely
difficult on the original chain so I
started with by practice model and I
showed you
general matching graph but it's saying
that vibrated variant can never be
stable right so what's going on with my
practice version in part participation
we are going to have arrivals that come
in pairs
one demand and one supply item at each
time this allows us to consider a
stability of the system
and these are complete resource pooling
our conditions and similarly here have
you obtained a product form using
exactly the same ideas but here the
ghost processors become a little bit
more complex because you also have
different populations so that's why I
wanted to first show you on the general
matching models because the idea is much
simpler for ah because I went fast on
this now I change the arrival process in
order to have stability I need to have
the exact amount of items of both
operations okay so
so they managed to show exactly the same
product form but doing without
reversibility proof so this is much
simpler proof they used skill based
queuing systems and then product form
for that and then they use projection on
this test space but it was not the same
description so it's not so it's not the
same so that's an excellent remark so if
I'm looking a kidnapper donation I need
to make sure that they treat the pair's
because otherwise people will just to
run when you take worgen of donor and
give it to a patient so the other donor
is just running somewhere else so I do
not consider this this is just open
variant of matching models so I do not
take this into account but you could
consider that as a rival pairs are just
one node and then I'm back to the non
bipartite case so I don't have much more
time so I'll just try to guide you
through it I will
I will just says a couple of results
about other policies that do not need to
take into account the complete
description of the history that items
arrived in the system so here imagine
that so we have you know what is the
matching graph now you can also take the
support of the probability arrival
distribution and consider driver graph
and then you can look into associate a
directed graph but I'm taking the
orientation from well this would be
demand demand to the supply and in this
graph I'm looking in the other direction
and then the result is that we have
non-empty stability stability region
I mean necessary conditions if and only
if for the disassociative graph is so
strongly connected so it's very easy to
check and then in that case any matching
policy has uniques
connected components secure connected
component and starting from any state
and going to this component so then we
also heard a lot about much the longest
or max weight policy it is also opposed
to here that has Maxima stability region
and the proof is just using quadratic
Lyapunov function but on a randomized
policy because we have some non
monotonicity issues that that are making
the direct analysis more complicated so
going to the using network floor
arguments it's it's much simpler for a
randomized Boise
okay they're voices that do not have
maximal stability region
as priority policies or much the
shortest and to answer your question
when they look into there are lots of
links between non bar Petitte and bar
part it's variant so here I can I can
cause I'm back to the non vibrated case
and I can consider another
representation of this non vibrated case
as I can represent it as a bipartite
case this time and where I will have
copy of each item sitting here and so we
were suggesting going from this
description here and then we can just
recover all the results that we had for
a vibrated case for the non bar padded
case and this was done by a Marisol
Marella in 2013 so I'm running out of
time so I'll just give you a summary of
the optimization that the problem that
we are considered so this is joint work
with Shawn mine and they looked into the
heavy traffic regime for these models
and so first of all what's a heavy
traffic here means so for this we need
to define what workload means and
workload in matching models is hard to
define because what is workload in
queueing models so we consider current
status of the system we stop the
arrivals and we walk how much time do I
need to empty the system well here if I
stop the arrivals nothing will ever
happen so this is the the first problem
we encountered and so okay just a little
bit of notation so we can see that's the
let's say just linear cost function and
we are trying to this allows us for
example to minimize the queue sizes and
it's useful when we want to study the
delays in the in the system and so in
order to define what workload here is we
need to look into the respawn conditions
and identify which conditions a
condition is the closest to its boundary
and so so as you can see here for any
subset of the demand set I'm looking
into the amount of items that belong to
this subset - the amount of items that
can be matched with this subset T and
then this this is natural here
definition of workload because it gives
us the time needed to reach to empty the
system but here we need to consider
arrivals okay we have two more minutes
one more minute so I'll skip the details
and you will have slides and there is
also a curve paper I'll just give you
the main result so it turns out that
under this heavy traffic set a setting
where we look at into one work work load
vector and be led to the difference
between the probabilities of arrival
probabilities both will go to zero in
that case we can get we can design a
policy that has some that is
asymptotically optimal be bounded regret
so the regret does not depend on this
Delta that tends to zero and the policy
is in a
mixture of Max late policy
but weeds of AIDS and so we have H max
weight policy but we also need
thresholds wide we don't we need
thresholds because to make sure that we
will not have reservation of the class
that that that is hard to match so this
is this is the high level idea and and
these are some miracle results so you
can see that this is for the for the
stability I can because it turns out
that policy that just looks into a
random class that is non empty also has
the built maximal stability region so
and the proof is we are once type of
construction so then for optimization
it's an open question
this city has a quick question
natural motion for I don't know I think
we should discuss this I didn't think
about that
I was trying to do models with
abandonments but this is extremely hard
so yeah so I I didn't walk into the
final buffer version of it
[Applause]